okay everyone we've been getting some
news about the upcoming Shazam movie
this week with an official photo from
the movie show exactly vying costume and
the director David Sandberg announced
that we will be seeing a trailer for the
movie at Comic Con next week so here's
just you know a primer of everything you
need to know about Shazam before you see
this trailer so you don't feel like a
dumb-dumb okay he's a classic superhero
from the DC Comics he's the alter ego of
a boy named Billy Batson Billy speaks
the magic word Shazam which is an
acronym of the six immortal elders
Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus Achilles and
Mercury and then he transforms into the
adult superhero with similar powers to
Superman now originally the adult
superhero was named Captain Marvel but
Marvel Comics released their own version
of a character named Captain Marvel or
Marvel so the DC version just eventually
started to go by Shazam to avoid
confusion but he goes by both names in
this one they're probably just gonna
calm Shazam now one of Shazam's primary
nemesis is Black Adam who has Dwayne the
rock Johnson attached to play him though
Black Adam will not appear in this movie
he hopefully will get his own movie
coming up no cameo either confirmed
right now they have announced that Jon
han-soo will be playing the wizard and
not to confuse you too much but the
Wizards name I think what Shazam right
but he's just being called the wizard
and later comics he's just known as the
wizard he's the 3000 year old bean who's
seeking a successor and he's the one who
gives Billy his powers so what do you
guys see Shazam bringing to the DC movie
universe that isn't there I mean
lightness right yeah from this is
actually from if you guys want a good
just a quick sum up of Shazam with a
really good story that's probably gonna
be what the movie is it's Jeff Johnson
Gary Frank did a Shazam story like four
years ago five years ago 52 it's really
good it's really pretty and if you guys
want just like a fun story and it's the
same thing that exact scene is from the
comic where he saved somebody like oh do
you want something they get soda and
they get the drink again
he's a kid also I found out why they
have the Lightning so small because
usually it goes all the way down his
body and so he can bend his oh yeah bend
his body in any direction so that's why
it's only right here like Superman I
think I like that Shazam more recently
has been kind of a comedic figure they
like realize what a fun idea it is to
put a child's brain in this man's body
yeah and I think that they played that
up a lot in the depiction it like even
the animated series woman when he shows
up he's just like a funnier character
the original versions of that were like
this real weird experience for me where
I was just like why does I couldn't get
why the character even existed honestly
yeah it was a moment way back in the day
that he was moved when he was first
introduced he was more popular than
Superman we are a long way away from
that now but this could be a cool
opportunity for DC to kind of do like
equal but opposite Deadpool something
that kind of like is an irreverent
version of the super story we're used to
but in a more lighthearted kid-friendly
way than Deadpool right like give Ferris
Bueller superpowers or something that's
a great yeah and it's in Captain Marvel
Shazam was always kind of confusing
because I think and it probably when you
and I were growing up it was more like
the classic comic for situation where
Shazam was actually a different person
than Billy was and yes like like why is
this exist then why do we need the Billy
part yeah like like Thor when the
Congress used to be Donald Blake and
then he his thing and then he became
four so it's like well then why is
Donald Blake they're like what's anyway
yeah this is fine and I love that it's
not beer very clear well let us know
what you're most looking forward to
from Shazam and as I said we will be
getting a trailer at least hopefully a
teaser some footage coming very soon at
Comic Con next week so we look forward
to breaking that down and pointing out
all the things that you missed from it
and as always subscribed into rock stars
for all of our coverage of the DC movie
universe and everything that you can
look forward to and thanks everybody